chez lui laurent beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes amis vous n'avez pas le choix
vous n'avez pas le choix
voilà ce que déclare emmanuel macron
dans son clip de campagne pour la
campagne des européennes
vous n'avez pas le choix
mais comment peut-on oser dire cela vous
n'avez pas le choix il n'y aurait que
lui et la lèpre nationaliste vous n'avez
pas le choix tous ceux qui ne sont pas
de son avis repoussé du côté des
ténèbres un seul chemin un seul isoloirs
et bien moi je crois qu'on a toujours le
choix je crois que les français ne se
laissent jamais dicter leurs volontés
je crois que le principe précisément de
l'élection à laquelle nous sommes
attachés et lire c'est choisir les
français ont toujours le choix et
personne ne leur dicte ce qu'ils ont à
faire
au moment des élections
et nous avons le choix pour l'europe et
c'est pour exercer ce choix que nous
sommes là il voudrait résumé le débat
européen à une seule alternative pour ou
contre l'europe
c'est une profonde erreur pour la
démocratie et pour l'europe il vaudrait
au fond tant rééditer le scénario du
second tour de la présidentielle
emmanuel macron et marine le pen se font
chacun la courte échelle prétendantes
étouffer toute autre parole mais nous
sommes là et quand je vous vois si
nombreux si enthousiaste si déterminé je
sais à quel point nous sommes là oui
j'en quelque chose est en train de se
passer dans le pays parce que la voix
des français refusent d'être confisquées
dans ce face-à-face mortifère car l'un
comme l'autre sont tous les deux des
impasses d'un côté marine le pen et
nicolas dupont aignan et la
déconstruction de l'europe
quand marine le pen propose de passer de
l'union européenne à l'alliance des
nations qu'est ce donc
sinon la déconstruction de l'europe
quand elles s'affichent symboliquement
avec un drapeau inversée de l'europe
qu'est ce donc
sinon la déconstruction de l'europe
quand elle dit qu'il faut reprendre
notre souveraineté monétaire nationale
nous qui avons tant de dette et de
déficit qu'est ce donc
sinon que l'abandon de l'euro ce serait
une catastrophe une catastrophe pour
l'économie de notre pays une catastrophe
pour le pouvoir d'achat
une catastrophe pour l'epargne pour tous
les français et surtout pour les
retraités qui ont déjà tant souffert au
cours des deux dernières années
et quand on disait cela parfois les gens
s'interrogeaient doutait mais
aujourd'hui il suffit de regarder de
l'autre côté de la manche
pour comprendre ce qui se passe le
discours qui a été tenu par les
partisans du bric site c'est le discours
de marine le pen et de nicolas dupont
aignan pour comprendre ce que sont les
conséquences de ces discours sans
conséquence eh bien c'est exactement de
l'autre côté de la manche qu'il faut
regarder
pour bien comprendre le chaos dans
lequel cela plongerait la france au
moment où les français voteront pour les
européennes
qu'il regarde bien du côté du royaume
uni pour comprendre à quel point cette
déconstruction de l'europe proposé par
marine le pen et nicolas dupont aignan
serait une faillite pour la france
mais l'autre approche est tout autant
une impasse ce que propose emmanuel
macron c'est toujours plus de l'europe
qui ne marche pas c'est une fuite en
avant dans le fédéralisme
impuissant le fédéralisme impuissance et
plus d'élargissement ce pourquoi
emmanuel macron a plaidé avec l'entrée
des pays des balkans dans l'europe comme
il l'a demandé de ses voeux dans son
discours de trieste le fédéralisme
impuissance et faire entrer la roumanie
dans l'espace schengen comme il l'a dit
à bucarest
alors que ce pays n'est pas prêt le
fédéralisme impuissance et toujours plus
de normes de bureaucratie lui qui
propose dans chacune de ses
interventions la création
d'administration et d' agences
supplémentaires
une quinzaine au total et l'on brasse
les mêmes slogans incantatoire que l'on
répète depuis des années
créer une europe sociale refonder
l'espace schengen et à l'arrivée rien ne
change
parce que hervé comme tu l'as dit tout
ceci repose sur le sable est sûre de
l'incantatoire pourquoi pourquoi cela
mais tout simplement parce que plus
personne ne veut de cette europe là oui
joseph la france avait soulevé un espoir
il y a deux ans et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui cher michel toi qui je dois
tant
eh bien la france est isolée isolé comme
elle l'a rarement été dans son histoire
nous nous sommes mis à dos nos
partenaires les uns après les autres
l'italie les pays nordiques la belgique
les pays bas et même maintenant notre
partenaire allemand
comment ne pas ressentir l'humiliation
de la fin de non recevoir opposée par la
présidente de l'ate cd ou allemandes à
toutes les propositions françaises
il y avait une époque où la france était
au coeur du jeu européen
c'était la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
et à l'époque quand un président
s'exprimait il est écouté et comment
évidemment la france pourrait-elle
aujourd'hui prétendre encore donner des
leçons à nos partenaires européens nous
qui avons maintenant le pire déficit
budgétaire de toute la zone euro ce qui
n'était jamais arrivé dans notre
histoire et qui avons franchi le record
des taxes des impôts et des prélèvements
obligatoires au sein de l'europe
aussi bien sur les ménages que sur les
industries à chaque fois que je parle à
nos partenaires européens
ils nous répondent mais qu emmanuel
macron commence par s'occuper de son
pays avant de nous donner des leçons sur
la conduite de l'europe
emmanuel macron marine le pen pour ou
contre l'europe
la même alternative stérile
les deux mêmes impasses qui interdisent
l'une comme l'autre d'apporter les
vraies réponses
ce que n'ont pas compris marine le pen
et nicolas dupont aignan et que savent
les français c'est que bien évidemment
face à la chine face aux états unis nous
avons besoin de l'europe qui est plus
que jamais une protection contre la
folie des temps qui viennent est ce que
n'a pas compris
emmanuel macron c'est que les français
ne sont pas contre l'europe
ils sont juste contre ce que l'europe
est devenue les français croient dans
l'europe il croit dans l'ambition
européenne
il croit dans la pertinence du projet
européen mais ils disent juste pourquoi
l'europe s'est écarté de ce que nous
attendions d'elle il croit dans l'europe
mais ils constatent chaque jour qu'elle
s'est écarté de sa mission initiale nous
assurer un surcroît de protection et
bien contre ces deux impasses la
déconstruction et la fuite en avant
notre responsabilité c'est d'être les
seuls à proposer de remettre l'europe
sur le bon chemin
nous sommes les seuls à proposer de
retrouver l'europe que nous aimons c'est
le message des républicains dans cette
campagne
et je suis évidemment fier de ce qu'ils
vont porter nos couleurs
vous le savez ce choix n'a pas été
facile et j'ai dû faire face à beaucoup
de doute beaucoup d'interrogations vous
connaissez mon tempérament plutôt
relativement déterminer quand on lui
oppose toutes les raisons pour ne rien
faire et ne rien changer et j'ai
souhaité que nous prenions ce trio parce
que j'étais convaincu que notre famille
politique avait besoin de ce nouveau
vent parce que j'étais convaincu que
notre famille politique avait besoin de
cette fraîcheur de ce renouvellement de
cette approche nouvelle et je remercie
chacun d'entre vous de m'avoir fait
confiance pour apporter cette décision
et cette rupture dans la conduite de
notre famille politique
arnaud danjean un spécialiste de la
lutte contre le terrorisme sujet qui
sera central pour les années qui
viennent
à l'échelle de l'europe agnès evren la
nouvelle génération
une femme qui a créé son entreprise et
dont vous avez apprécié le dynamisme
elle qui s'occupe maintenant de la
fédération de paris avec talent et les
militants m
l'énergie qu'elle y amenait
et françois-xavier bellamy qui guide
notre liste parce que la politique a
besoin de vision parce qu'elle a besoin
de reprendre de la hauteur parce que la
politique ça ne peut pas être ces
successions d'image avilissante et de
petit buzz médiatique qui nous tire vers
le bas
je crois dans la nécessité de redonner
de la vision je crois dans cet au delà
de la colline dont parlait lincoln je
crois dans ce que peut apporter un
philosophe à la réflexion de notre
famille politique et je suis très
heureux de voir le courage avec lequel
françois xavier bellamy a fait face il a
déjoué d'ores et déjà tous les
pronostics
il a redonné un élan et je suis très
fier de son engagement dans notre liste
et à leurs côtés il y a une équipe qui
est fait de la diversité des expériences
et du renouvellement des talents mais
ils vous disent tous une chose
la chose qui est pour moi la plus
précieuse
ils vous disent c'est une droite qui
avance en relevant la tête
ils vous disent ce sont des
personnalités de conviction ils vous
disent c'est avec eux que la
reconstruction commence et déjà les
lignes se sont mises à bouger en à peine
quelques semaines mais les convictions
je crois dans les convictions et je
crois dans les convictions qui rassemble
je veux remercier devant vous et hervé
morin de sa confiance
hervé et moi nous nous connaissons bien
et j'apprécie avec lui le fait qu'une
parole donnée soit une parole tenue
nous avons tous les deux deux forts
caractères et nous nous sommes tout de
suite plu quand nous avons commencé à
discuter ensemble
hervé est un homme droit c'est un homme
engagé
c'est le président des régions de france
et ils défient avec force tout ce qui
est le centralisme de ce gouvernement
c'est le président des centristes
la vraie voix du centre celle qui n'a
pas oublié ce qu'est la tradition
historique du centre dans notre pays et
les valeurs qu'ils ont toujours habité
hervé tu nous honore en faisant ce soit
de construire ensemble cet autre chemin
pour l'europe et pour la france et nous
montrons au delà des élections
européennes que nous voulons construire
ce chemin d'une nouvelle alliance de la
droite et du centre pour aujourd'hui et
pour demain
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui est une
pierre essentielle dans la
reconstruction qui viendra demain merci
de votre soutien à hervé morin
et je voudrais enfin remercié softball
voter pour les républicains mes amis il
faut vous en ayez confiance c'est
inscrire la france dans la grande
famille du ppe
la famille du ppe c'est le premier parti
européen les élus dans marche ne savent
même pas dans quel groupe ils siégeront
au parlement européen c'est l'assurance
que nous n'aurons aucune influence et
que toutes les voix qui se porteront sur
eux seront des voix perdues pour le
rayonnement de la france au niveau de
bruxelles perdu avec nous avec joseph
c'est la garantie que la france pourra
défendre ses intérêts et enfin vous me
le pardonnerai mais dans notre région
dans ma région que j'adore et que je
défende tout coeur je voudrais aussi
remercier charlotte
merci à charlotte de son engagement à
mes côtés et c'est tellement de chance
de l'avoir
pourquoi sommes-nous là pourquoi sommes
nous là parce que nous croyons dans le
destin de l'europe
j'ai dit l'europe je n'ai pas dit
l'union européenne j'ai dit l'europe
parce que je pense d'abord à l'europe
je pense d'abord en disant l'europe à
notre mode de vie à notre civilisation
nous voyons en ce moment la chine et les
états unis s'affirmer nous voyons monter
cette menace de l'islamisme et de ce
qu'il représente
nous voyons les défis du climat de la
mondialisation du digital et nous nous
disons est ce que demain l'europe pèsera
encore nous sentons bien au fond de nous
que l'europe est menacée et nous nous
posons cette question nous qui avons
fait pendant des siècles la marche du
progrès sommes nous donc condamnés par
nos lâchetés et nos aveuglements à
quitter le train de l'histoire à bas
bruit
sommes nous condamnés à ne plus nous
défendre à ne plus assumer notre
héritage à ne plus influer sur le cours
des événements mais a mis l'europe ne
doit pas devenir le nom d'un vide
notre bataille c'était celle dont parle
m ilan kundera en 1983
notre bataille elle est tellement plus
importante que toutes les esbroufes
politicienne notre bataille qu'elle et
elle sait redonner un avenir à la
civilisation européenne
c'est cela la bataille de cette élection
européenne
j'ai dit civilisation ce monde
merveilleux
ce mot françois-xavier que l'on hausse
plus prononcée sans s'excuser
depuis trop d'années nous avons perdu
l'amour de nous mêmes nous n'assumons
plus la fierté de notre être
nous avons renoncé au droit d'être nous
mêmes eh bien je veux que nous
retrouvions ce goût
je veux que nous retrouvions le sens de
ce que nous sommes comme nous y invite
le philosophe permanent on a le droit
d'aimer ce que nous sommes
on a le droit de chérir cette
civilisation européenne valéry oui
rappelons nous ce qu'est d'abord
l'europe l'europe c'est une civilisation
l'europe ce n'est pas une construction
administrative ça n'est même pas une
série de traiter ça n'est pas l'addition
de droits individuels en bâtissant
l'union européenne
nous ne devons jamais oublier que nous
construisons sur le sol d'une
civilisation redonner un avenir à notre
civilisation européenne c'est se
souvenir que l'europe a une histoire
comme sentant le mot d'europe me vient à
l'esprit les batailles menées par la
grèce contre la perse l'arrogance
extraordinaire et miraculeuse d'un
leonidas aux thermopyles l'europe c'est
ce miracle de la démocratie athénienne
celle de périclès celle que défendait
avec ardeur démosthène dans ses discours
l'europe c'est le rayonnement du droit
romain de cette rom qui avait compris le
son qu'on ne devrait pas oublier
aujourd'hui que pour qu'un empire tienne
il y faut des règles et il faut
s'assurer que ces citoyens respectent
les règles parce que sans autorité il
n'y a pas de construction politique qui
tienne l'europe
l'europe c'est cette bataille des champs
catalauniques au l'union des romains des
francs et des wisigoths qui ont semé les
graines de ce qui est allé être demain
l'histoire de l'europe ont permis de
repousser les hordes d'attila l'europe
c'est ce fruit lentement mûri aux marges
de lempire dans les batailles sur la
méditerranée dans l'élan de l'art
concouristes à roko fin de l'empiré
ibérique et qui a permis petit à petit
d'édifier à la fois le territoire et la
conscience européenne l'europe c'est
tout cela l'europe c'est tout cela et
redonner un avenir à la civilisation
européenne
c'est assumer nos racines l'europe est
fondé sur trois traditions la tradition
gréco-latine la tradition
judéo-chrétienne et la tradition des
lumières qui donnera naissance en suite
au mouvement de la révolution et du
progrès cette pensée gens ce sont ces
grandes figures qui ont voulu comprendre
le monde
aristote saint-thomas ou des cartes
trois merveilleuses tradition qui se
sont unis pour donner naissance à la
plus belle des civilisations une
civilisation construite sur l'humanisme
et le respect et bien mes amis dans une
mondialisation déséquilibre est
caractérisée par les excès et par
l'hubris nous avons besoin que la voix
de l'europe ne s'éteigne pas plus que
jamais je suis convaincu que le destin
du 21e siècle a besoin de cette voie de
l'europe fait d' équilibre et de
modération
et c'est pour cela que nous devons être
à la pointe de la prise de conscience
écologique car en europe l'histoire nous
a appris qu'il fallait se fixer des
limites et que même si la science est en
progrès la folie des hommes peut être
destructrice
l'europe c'est l'espérance et la liberté
d'expression c'est ce continent où le
tribut payé aux guerres nous affirmons
appris à refuser qu un totalitarisme
politique ou religieux dicté en europe
sa loi l'europe c'est ce lieu où l'on
respecte la foi mais où la foi doit
aussi respecter la liberté des
consciences
l'europe c'est le continent de l'égalité
de l'homme et de la femme et c'est pour
cela que chez nous personne ne doivent
jamais pouvoir dicter à une femme de se
couvrir le visage
l'europe l'europe ce sont ses racines
ce sont elles qui nous ont façonné et on
ne peut construire l'avenir de l'europe
en leur tournant le dos alors oui bien
sûr l'europe a des racines chrétiennes
n'ayons pas peur de le dire parce que
c'est une évidence même pour les
européens qui ne sont ni croyant ni
pratiquant ce socle constitue le socle
de notre identité
si nous tenons tant à distinguer le
temporel et le spirituel
c'est grâce à nos racines chrétiennes si
nous préservons notre ambition humaniste
ces graphes à nos racines chrétiennes
c'est une évidence
et pourtant comme nous avons failli par
le passé quand nous avons été incapables
d'inscrire ses racines dans notre été
européen
et bien mes amis finissons-en avec cet
éternel repentance qui nous interdit
d'aimer ce que nous sommes
on m'a attaquée comme j'ai défendu ses
symboles de notre histoire mais je les
fais et j'ai refusé de céder parce
qu'une église une crèche
c'est plus qu'une église c'est plus
qu'une crèche c'est un symbole de ce que
nous sommes et de ce qu'est notre
identité
nos traditions ne seront jamais un
fardeau nos traditions c'est une force
et nous demandons à ce que nos racines
judéo chrétiennes soit inscrite dans nos
traités fondateurs pour nous sortir de
toutes ces années mortifère de
repentance mais j'ai bien dit les
racines judéo chrétiennes car nous
devons tant à la culture juive et cette
culture nous oblige
et quand on attaque des juifs en europe
on attaque la civilisation européenne
c'est pour cela que je souhaite que
demain nos députés portent un pacte
européen contre l'antisémitisme
parce qu'il faut combattre en unissant
tous les pays européens
le fléau que représente l'antisémitisme
et l'europe
je pense aussi à mes enfants c'est l'art
de la figuration qui va de léonard de
vinci aux impressionnistes
c'est l'invention de l'art du roman par
cervantès c'est la poésie de dante
c'est la magie de l'opéra rares européen
par excellence
l'europe c'est l'art des cafés de vienne
ou de paris l'europe c'est les créateurs
de mode
l'europe c'est le cinéma l'europe c'est
la musique pop
ce sont toutes ces trésors toutes ces
images qui nous constitue et qui font
notre référentiel commun
et pourquoi ne les enseignes ton plus à
nos enfants
pourquoi nous leur transmettons plus la
fierté de cet héritage dont ils seront à
leur tour un jour les héritiers et
qu'ils transmettront à leur tour un jour
avenue ou petits enfants
où sont ces images dans l'europe
d'aujourd'hui elles ne sont plus dans
nos discours
elles ne sont pas dans les documents
officiels elles ne sont pas dans les
édifices de bruxelles elles ne sont plus
dans nos écoles sur nos billets symbole
politique par excellence depuis les
romains
nous n'avons pas de figure nous n'avons
pas de devises
nous n'avons pas de visage nous n'avons
que des ponts imaginaire et des
constructions abstraites
pourquoi ne pas mettre sur nos futurs
billets de roue les visages de
charlemagne de christophe colomb de
goethe ou de mozart pour nous rappeler
qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité à perdre
l'identité culturelle européenne
la culture and yes we la culture mais
qui parle de culture qui sont les
politiques et quand on aborde la
question européenne parle de culture il
y à peine 0 15% du budget européen qui
est consacrée à la culture et au
patrimoine
eh bien nous proposons que dans les cinq
ans qui viennent on se fixe le même
objectif que celui qui a été celui de la
france et qu'il y ait un pour cent du
budget européen qu'ils soient consacrés
à la promotion de la culture et du
patrimoine européen redonner un avenir à
notre civilisation européenne
redonner un avenir à notre civilisation
européenne c'est aussi défendre notre
mode de vie
l'europe ne peut pas tout accepter être
ouverte à tous tout en reniant ce
qu'elle est n'oubliez jamais qu'à
bruxelles ville que je connais bien
à deux pas des institutions européennes
il y a le quartier de molenbeek et cela
résume tout l'europe avait pourtant un
très vieux principe qui avait été
formulée par saint-augustin à rome fais
comme les romains
nous avons cessé de l'exiger et nous
avons laissé s'installer le
communautarisme
même angela merkel a dressé ce constat
le multiculturalisme a totalement échoué
oui mes amis
le multiculturalisme est aujourd'hui un
danger pour la civilisation européenne
le devoir
le devoir d'intégration ne peut être
inversé les nouveaux arrivants doivent
avoir à coeur de faire leur le mode de
vie européen et nous proposons cher eric
toi qui est si constant sur ce sujet
cher guillaume d'exiger de chaque nouvel
arrivant en europe qu'ils signent une
charte des valeurs et des devoirs
européen qu'il devra respecter sous
peine d'expulsion l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes la liberté de
conscience la liberté d'expression en
europe
ça ne se négocie pas
redonner un avenir à notre civilisation
européenne s'est donc arrêté de
sous-estimer la menace islamiste
une partie de nos élites ne cesse de
minorer l'islamisme et je veux saluer
ici le courage et la constance de notre
porte parole lydia guirous ce qu'aucune
menace n'impressionne dans son combat
contre l'islamisme
merci à toi lydia merci de la vigueur de
ton engagement car ne nous y trompons
pas il faudra vaincre ensemble les
terroristes islamistes
car ne nous y trompons pas tous les pays
ont été frappées par les attentats
ces deux attentats ne sont pas le fruit
du hasard
je suis allé à mossoul shirani voir les
minorités chrétiennes qui ont fait face
à la barbarie islamiste
celle qui déteste tout ce que nous
sommes
ils veulent détruire ce que nous
représentons parce qu'il ne supporte pas
cette voie qui se dresse face own alors
arrêtons d'être naïf il faut arnaud tu
l'as dit un bouclier européen contre
l'islamisme et une coopération contre le
terrorisme
fermons comme certains pays ont commencé
à le faire et comme j'aimerais que la
france le fasse enfin fermons toutes les
mosquées salafistes d'europe
arrêtons les financements étrangers en
europe et expulsion tous les imams qui
sont prêcheurs de haine du continent
européen
et je ne veux pas que les jihadistes
partis en syrie ou en irak puisse
revenir sur le sol européen
je ne sous estime pas la difficulté du
sujet et pour éviter tout retour
je propose que l'europe prenne
l'initiative en irak d'un tribunal pénal
international d'un nuremberg des
djihadistes qui pourrait prononcer des
peines d'exception ainsi serait-il jugés
condamnés et détenus sur place ils ont
trahi leur l'europe
ils n'ont plus leur place sur le
continent européen
et sur ce sujet je compte sur
l'expertisé que nous apportera frédéric
péchenard un ancien directeur général de
la police nationale sur une liste
européenne dans la période actuelle
ça doit pouvoir servir merci frédéric
[Applaudissements]
redonner un avenir à notre civilisation
européenne c'est en finir avec
l'élargissement sans fin et ce sera à
mes amis une de nos différences majeures
avec le programme dont marc emmanuel
macron accepter que l'ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion avec l'albanie
et la macédoine comme par hasard
s'entame en juin prochain juste après
les élections européennes
tous ceux qui sont ici et qui nous
représenteront signeront une charte
d'engagement dans laquelle ils
s'engageront pendant la totalité de leur
mandat a voté contre toutes les
décisions qui ouvrirait la voie à de
nouveaux élargissements toutes les
nouveaux élargissements et je demande
également la suppression du poste de
commissaire européen à l'élargissement
et nous portons avec la cd ou la même
exigence que l'on mette fin une bonne
fois pour toutes aux négociations avec
la turquie
que l'on sorte enfin de ce jeu hypocrite
[Applaudissements]
redonner un avenir à notre civilisation
européenne brice s'est redonné des
fondations solides et ses fondations tu
l'as toujours défendu elles sont dans
nos différentes nations constitutives de
notre identité
l'essence même de l'europe c'est
l'émulation entre les nations
européennes
certains ont cru pouvoir construire
l'europe sur les décombres des nations
mais c'était une profonde erreur et
cette erreur consistant à opposer
l'europe et les nations
chacun de la même manière emmanuel
macron et marine le pen
la comète car il pense que l'on peut
ainsi opposé l'europe et les nations
mais les nations sans l'europe serait
démuni et l'europe sont les nations se
re est inexistante
le projet européen doit renforcer les
nations européennes et les nations
européennes doivent renforcer l'europe
pour que l'europe avance elle doit
s'appuyer sur les nations et les peuples
quand nous pensons aujourd'hui à
l'europe nous pensons d'abord à la
commission et aux directives c'est ce
qui doit changer
je veux que l'on pense d'abord quand on
pense à l'union européenne au conseil
des états et au parlement européen le
conseil d etat parce que seuls les
représentants des nations européennes
sont à même de décider de l'avenir de
l'europe et le parlement parce que les
députés européens sont élus directement
par les citoyens
et ce parlement joseph doivent avoir un
seul siège
je suis d'accord là dessus avec la
présidente de la ceni il faut un seul
siège par souci de simplification et ce
siège unique
il doit être à strasbourg il doit être
en france parce que ce sont les traités
fondateurs
je ne lâcherai rien sur cette question
je ne demande pas que la bce ne soit
plus à francfort qu'on ne demande pas
que le parlement européen ne soit plus à
strasbourg et vous le savez il faut le
faire parce que strasbourg c'est quelque
chose de plus c'est quelque chose d'un
team
c'est une petite voix c'est une partie
de ce qu'est l'amour au pn strasbourg
c'est cette incarnation de la
civilisation rhennam qui est la
confluence entre la tradition germanique
et la tradition romaine que notre pays
est incarnée c'est pour cela que
strasbourg est indispensable parce que
strasbourg nous rappelle aussi quand on
est à strasbourg qu'il n'y a pas que la
technocratie qu'il n'y a pas que la
bureaucratie qu'il n'ya pas que les
institutions qu'il ya quelque chose de
plus c'est pour cela qu'on a besoin de
strasbourg
redonner un avenir à notre civilisation
européenne c'est aussi sortir geoffroy
de l'europe de ce que tocqueville
appelait ses petites règles compliquées
minutieuse uniforme dont il disait
qu'elle gêne qu elles compriment qu'elle
énerve qu'elle est n y ait qu elle est
bête mais comme nous avons perdu le bon
sens parce que nous ne faisons plus rien
nous croyons que l'on peut faire
semblant de faire quelque chose quand
l'on adapte des normes parce que nous ne
portons plus de projets nous nous sommes
réfugiés dans le droit et dans les
diction des textes parce que l'on a cru
qu'un si la politique y trouveraient un
dérivatif à son incapacité à puiser dans
son courage et dans ses convictions
la force de changer le cours du temps
comme je n'aime pas ces normes folle qui
sont une fuite en avant que la france a
transposé à l'échelle de bruxelles et
bien que la france commence par se fixer
un principe elle qui va toujours plus
loin en la matière quand une directive
européenne nous laisse le choix que la
france s'oblige à prendre
systématiquement la norme la moins
contraignante comme le font bien
d'autres pays en europe
mais ça ne suffit pas je veux que l'on
aille plus loin
je veux que l'on passe de cette europe
des normes à l'europe des projets je
veux pour cela joseph que l'on puisse
limiter au strict minimum la compétence
normative de la commission mais en
revanche je souhaite que l'on puisse
confier à la commission le pouvoir de
conduire elle-même de grands projets
d'infrastructures en lui donnant la
compétence de maîtrise d'ouvragé que la
commission s'impliquent et qu'elle porte
elle même la réalisation du lyon turin
qui permettrait de sortir les camions de
nos vallées et de les mettre sur les
chemins de fer que la commission
européenne puisse elle même veiller à la
réalisation d'une grande ligne à grande
vitesse qui unirait de prague à madrid
en remettant la france au coeur de
l'europe que la commission européenne
puisse elle même porté le projet de
couverture du continent européen
en une infrastructure à 5 g qui
permettrait de sortir toute une partie
de nos territoires de l' isolement
que l'on parle de la commission
européenne à travers ces projets comme
les pères fondateurs l'avez compris il
avait compris cette leçon indispensable
vous voulez parler aux peuples d'europe
fait vous reconnaître par les projets
que vous portez et non par les normes
que vous édictées
et j'ai cette ambition que je veux que
nous fassions notre et sur lesquels
j'aurai besoin de chacun d'entre vous je
veux que l'europe se fixe pour les cinq
ans qui viennent une grande cause
européenne que cette grande cause
européenne consiste à unifier le travail
de tous les laboratoires de recherche en
europe et que ce travail nous permettent
de concentrer nos efforts sur les
remèdes à apporter face alzheimer et aux
maladies neurodégénératives qui laisse
tant de familles en europe désemparé je
rêve mes amis que nous qui avons été le
continent de marie curie nous puissions
dire d'ici à cinq ans que l'europe soit
le continent où nous avons trouvé la
réponse
alzheimer et aux maladies
neurodégénératives
c'est possible mais il faut que nous
nous y investit sion et que nous en
fassions notre priorité
[Applaudissements]
redonner un avenir enfin notre
civilisation européenne c'est bâtir une
europe capable de répondre aux enjeux de
demain ceux de la nouvelle révolution
industrielle de l'intelligence
artificielle cher bernard de l'homme
augmenté
l'europe doit regagner le terrain perdu
face au ghana et au bea thé xx qui
pillent nos données personnelles
il ne s'agit pas seulement de les
fiscaliser ce qui est en soi déjà une
renonciation
le sujet c'est beaucoup plus que sans le
sujet cher michel comme tu l'as si bien
dit c'est évidemment de faire émerger
nos propres champions le sujet c'est de
reconquérir l'autonomie qui nous
permettra de fixer nos propres règles
sur la frontière technologique
il faut que ce soit l'europe qui est la
capacité de fixer les limites éthiques
entre ce que nous pouvons faire et ce
que nous voulons faire
cela fera partie des défis majeurs qui
seront face à nous car nous sommes à un
moment où la civilisation peut changer
de forme et changer de contenu et la
morale l'éthique c'est précisément
choisir entre ce que la science permet
est ce qu'une société décide de faire
nous aurons besoin de cet appui et de
cette réflexion commune
alors oui cette quête de la souveraineté
qui est la quête aussi de ce sens qu'il
faut redonner à la civilisation
européenne cela passe par le fait
d'ouvrir les yeux
il n'ya plus trafalgar il n'y a plus ou
un terreau l'eau mais il ya de nouvelles
batailles qui sont tout aussi redoutable
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
ces batailles sont les batailles
économiques ces batailles sont celles
qui menace l'europe de déclassement ces
batailles
ce sont celles que nous subissons quand
nous perdons des fleurons comme alstom
etc on le fait en plus en sont
réjouissants et en faisant les ravis de
la crèche
l'europe doit cesser d'être naïve ou
soumise elle doit redevenir conquérante
et audacieuse comment accepter que
donald trump nous dicte ses volontés et
puisse dire du jour au lendemain aux
pays européens je vous interdis
maintenant de commercer avec l'iran
comment accepter que la chine puisse
ainsi petit à petit s'acheter les unes
après les autres nos grandes
infrastructures les ports européens
hier les ports italiens aujourd'hui et
demain les aéroports français si nous
n'y prenons garde
moi je sais je souhaite cher brice que
l'europe devienne à nouveau son rang
qu'elle assume ce rapport de force
qu'elle redevienne une puissance notre
vocation
ça ne peut pas être de devenir petit à
petit un continent peuplé de supermarché
où l'on pousse des caddies en achetant
dans une société de consommation des
produits qui ont quasiment tous été
fabriqués en dehors du continent
européen
il faut défendre il faut défendre le
consommateur mais il faut d'abord
défendre le travail il faut d'abord
défendre le salarié il faut d'abord
défendre les entreprises
je crois au libre échange mais je ne
crois pas dans la concurrence déloyale
et faux c je veux que nous rétablissions
des règles du jeu qui soit équilibrée en
matière de marchés publics le savez vous
nous ouvrons quasiment 90% nos marchés
publics européens la concurrence les
états unis à peine 40% la chine 0% et
bien que l'europe prenne l'initiative et
qu'elle nous autorise à nouveau à
soustraire au moins les deux tiers de
nos marchés publics à une concurrence
automatique en disant aux autres pays
vous n'ouvrez pas vos marchés publics
vous n'aurez pas accès au marché
européen on ne rentre pas chez nous
comme dans un moulin
et nous proposons de mettre en oeuvre
une barrière écologique
nous croyons dans l'écologie mais si
nous nous assignons à nous mêmes des
règles qu aucun autre pays du monde nous
respecte
à l'arrivée que se passe-t-il nos
produits ne sont plus compétitifs nous
finissons par acheter les produits qui
ont été faits à l'étranger dans des pays
qui ne respectent aucune des règles
à l'arrivée c'est le même air c'est la
même eau la seule chose c'est que la
chine la polluent à notre place et que
nous nous perdons nos emplois nos
produits nos entreprises et nos savoir
faire et bien que l'on réinstaure la
justice et l'équité que l'on mette une
barrière écologique à l'entrée sur le
marché européen
quand les autres ne respectent pas nos
règles et cher angélique vers le rond
cela passe évidemment par le fait de
retrouver une ambition agricole nos
députés se battront pour conserver le
montant de la politique agricole commune
ceux qui me connaissent savent à quel
point c'est un sujet qui me passionne
parce qu'en france l'agriculture
c'est beaucoup plus que l'agriculture
l'agriculture c'est notre richesse
l'agriculture c'est un support d'emplois
l'agriculture ce sont nos terroirs et
l'agriculture aussi c'est une part de ce
qu'est notre identité notre continent
qui s'est construit à travers cela est
même pas besoin de revenir jusqu'à henri
iv pour savoir à quel point dans la
politique française l'agriculture et
l'histoire sont intimement liés et l'on
voudrait maintenant elle en voudrait
maintenant baisser pavillon
et l'on voudrait maintenant baisser
pavillon
et l'on voudrait au moment où on n'a
jamais eu autant besoin d'assurer notre
souveraineté alimentaire de veiller à ce
que nos consommateurs soit nourrie par
de bons produits dont nous soyons
capables d'assurer la traçabilité
on voudrait renoncé à l'ambition
agricoles européennes
eh bien je ne le laisserai pas faire
le budget de la politique agricole doit
être sanctuarisée
car il en va de notre souveraineté
alimentaire et il faut enfin et il faut
enfin que nous ouvrions les yeux mais
parfois vous savez on finit par
succomber à la folie voilà des sociétés
dans lesquelles on parle de
développement durable et de lutte
climatique mais on est capable de pêcher
le cabillaud en norvège de le
conditionner ensuite en chine et de le
donner après surgelés dans les cantines
à nos enfants
vous voulez du développement durable
retrouver d'abord de la lucidité et du
bon sens revenons à demander à nos
enfants
les produits qui sont fabriqués par
notre agriculture redonner un avenir à
notre civilisation européen c'est enfin
mes amis ne plus subir l'immigration de
masse c'est être capable de défendre ses
frontières
nous avons fini par oublier le sens de
la frontière quand romulus et rémus
fondre hommes il commence par tracer le
sillon la frontière qui permet de
distinguer ce qui est chez soi et ce qui
est ailleurs la frontière ça n'est pas
les ténèbres la frontière c'est l'espace
de la rencontre c'est l'espace deûle
échanges
c'est l'espace de la discussion mais
c'est aussi l'espace de la protection
dans l'histoire des constructions
politiques de tout temps la première
chose que nous attendons de toute
construction politique quelle qu'elle
soit c'est d'assurer cette protection de
la frontière
si nous continuons à dépasser
durablement nos capacités d'intégration
chaire nadine nos pays ne tiendront pas
tu as été une des premières à le dire
avec le courage et l'énergie que j'aime
chez toi avec le défi climatique
c'est sans doute à nos principaux défis
pour les années qui viennent pour cela
oui il faut défendre nos frontières
européennes et c'est encore un de ses
objet symbolique où l'on voit à la fois
l'erreur de marine le pen et celle d'
emmanuel macron marine le pen a tort
quand elle pense qu'il ne faut pas que
l'europe défende nos frontières
européennes
moi je suis allé à lesbos je suis allé
dans ces îles qui font face à la turquie
parce que je voulais voir moi-même ce
que cela signifiait et j'ai vu j'ai vu
l'ampleur de cette immigration illégale
qui arrivent chaque jour en europe
poussé par les trafiquants et les
passeurs j'ai vu le travail quotidien
des garde-côtes
j'ai vu la pression qui existe sur ces
territoires et ses habitants et qui
viendra ensuite dans notre pays et je le
dis il faut être aveugle pour comme
marine le pen dire qu'il ne faut pas que
l'europe défende nos frontières parce
que quand ils passent par l'italie
quand ils passent par l'espagne quand
ils passent par la grèce et bien ensuite
il arrive en france il est évident qu'il
faut une défense européenne de nos
frontières mais mais emmanuel macron
fait également une erreur quand il pense
qu'il faut juste répartir les migrants
entre les pays européens
cela c'est gérer notre impuissance
moi je veux qu'on arrête les migrants
illégaux avant qu'il ne rentre en europe
je souhaite qu'on organise le retour
systématique des bateaux des passeurs
sur les côtes africaines pour faire
cesser le trafic d'êtres humains
emmanuel macron a proposé d'ouvrir de
nouveaux centres d'accueil en europe
eh bien nous nous pensons au contraire
qu'il faut retrouver la fermeté
nécessaire les demandes d'asile doivent
être faites hors d'europe est un immigré
entrés illégalement doit savoir qu'il ne
saura pas régularisés mais qu'il sera un
systématiquement reconduits dans son
pays car sinon c'est une incitation à
violer les règles de droit et je crois
dans le respect de ses règles
alors ce que nous proposons c'est
d'établir une double frontières ce que
nous proposons c'est une double
protection une frontière européenne
défendue en commun et une frontière
nationale
chaque pays gardant la possibilité comme
à menton d'arrêter les immigrés illégaux
d'eau bleue frontière doblo protection
c'est la proposition des républicains
dans cette bataille pour les européennes
bien sûr mes amis je ne sous-estime rien
de la difficulté du sujet personne ne
peut rester insensible à ces drames
humains à ces morts qui sont dans la
méditerranée mais parfois il n'y a rien
de plus cruel que la fausse générosité
il n'y a rien de plus dangereux que la
lâcheté la vraie générosité aujourd'hui
c'est de soutenir un vrai plan de
développement de l'afrique
portée par l'europe la vraie générosité
c'est d'avoir le courage de dire que
l'avenir de la jeunesse africaine n'est
pas en europe
la vraie générosité c'est de dire qu'il
faut faire en sorte que l'avenir de la
jeunesse africaine puisse être en
afrique
et là c'est la responsabilité de
l'europe
[Applaudissements]
réaffirmer le sens de la frontière
arrêter de subir ne plus se soumettre
retrouvé le goût de l'ambition et de la
conquête redessiné l'avenir de cette
civilisation européenne que nous
chérissons se réapproprier ce que nous
sommes
pour mieux assurer ce que nous serons
c'est cela la vraie question qui nous
attend pas pour ou contre l'europe mais
l'europe que nous voulons
alors mes amis les temps
les lignes sont en train de bouger il
est temps ils ont voulu écrire un
scénario d' avance mais les français
n'en veulent pas ils ne veulent pas être
à nouveau enfermé dans le duel de la
présidentielle les français veulent
autre chose il est temps depuis que nous
avons commencé à redresser la tête je
sens quelque chose qui est en train de
se passer dans notre pays nous allons
déjouer les pronostics
nous allons bousculer les certitudes
nous allons faire mentir toutes les
prévisions qu'ils avaient voulu écrire à
notre place nous allons faire se lever
un nouvel espoir
il est temps il est temps de rendre aux
français l'europe qu'il vole ce que nous
voulons au fond c'est à la fois simple
et gigantesque ce que nous voulons c'est
continuer l'histoire de notre
civilisation l'histoire de nation
l'histoire deux peuples l'histoire de
culture dont le génie lucide et
millénaire ne veut pas mourir
ce que nous voulons c'est redonner un
avenir à la civilisation européenne
il est temps revenons cet avenir à la
civilisation européenne
soyons-en digne soyons en fiers vive la
france et vive le rap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui